hey 42 here if there's one thing we love
in the 21st century it's worshiping at
the altar of celebrity
you may assume it's a modern phenomenon
like when you order a coffee and have to
choose between an ever-expanding variety
of milk each inexplicably squeezed from
a small round ingredient that I'm 99
sure doesn't even contain milk anyway
there have always been those who are
idolized and those who idolize them and
when it comes to celebrities one thing
has always been true the badder they are
the more we love them
in 1930s America the general public
became absolutely obsessed with those
who earned their coveted title of Public
Enemy the likes of Bonnie and Clyde Ma
Barker Pretty Boy Floyd and Machine Gun
Kelly all experienced Mass Fame which
was usually followed by fatal gunfire
from the feds
but perhaps the most legendary of them
all was John Dillinger one of just six
men in history to be branded Public
Enemy Number One
Dillinger was a different breed of
criminal don't get me wrong he was a
human not a turtle but he was a bank
rubbing Pioneer whose groundbreaking
method is still used to this day this is
a man who once bluffed his way out of
prison with a pistol he'd whittled from
wood who robbed at your police stations
in order to stock up on supplies of guns
and ammo and who when things went South
hired a rogue plastic surgeon to alter
his appearance through the Strategic use
of kangaroo tendons and highly
concentrated acid which also happened to
be ingredients in the latest goop
moisturizer his level of notoriety
reached such dizzying Heights that when
he met his inevitably grisly end fans
flocked to the scene to dip their
clothes in pools of his blood
this is the remarkable story of John
Dillinger Public Enemy Number One
[Music]
storyblocks is a vast curated stock
library with over a million high quality
4K and HD footage templates music sound
effects images and so much more and the
best part they offer unlimited downloads
of royalty-free professional content for
one predictable subscription cost say
goodbye to expensive pay-per-clip
pricing plus you can choose a monthly or
annual plan with no hidden extra fees I
love using story blocks for our Channel
because anything I download with
storyblocks is 100 royalty free forever
with no restrictions on where you can
distribute your finished projects and if
you're like me and you use Adobe
Creative Cloud you can save a ton of
time by using the storyblocks plugin
this allows you to access the entire
storyblocks library right inside
Premiere Pro and after effects also you
can choose from thousands of pre-made
professional templates for your favorite
editing program including After Effects
Premiere Pro and apple motion this takes
your videos to the next level and really
speeds up your creative workflow by
letting you easily add Motion Graphics
title animations overlays and Logo
reveals to supercharge the production
value of your videos to get started with
unlimited stock media downloads at one
set price head to storyblocks.com 42 or
click the link in the description and a
big thanks to storyblocks for sponsoring
this video
born in Indianapolis in 1903 Dillinger's
father ruled the home with an Iron Fist
and his mother died when he was just
three years old
after his mum passed away Dillinger's
dad doubled down on his dickish Deed by
sending his devastated son to dwell with
that older dista I mean sister Dillinger
senior used this peace and quiet to find
himself a new wife his dinners weren't
going to cook themselves now were they
and little John got on with his new
stepmom about as well as Cinderella did
with hers
in trouble from a young gay jalander
dropped out of school as a teenager to
instead pursue his twin passions of
drinking and shoplifting at 19 he joined
the Navy but not because he had any real
interest in being in a military man
sorry I meant being a military man he
was wanted by the police for stealing a
car and a few months on a boat far from
the mainland seemed like a perfect way
to avoid capture no surprise Dillinger
didn't take well to the disciplined life
of a sailor so he returned home after a
few months with a dishonorable discharge
Dylan drexi made an attempt to leave his
life of petty crying behind marrying 16
year old beryl hovius and applying for a
string of jobs but unable to land any he
instead started his own business in
unauthorized wealth redistribution
otherwise known as stealing his new
business venture was so successful he
soon earned himself a vacation in prison
he was given 10 to 20 years in The
Slammer for Morgan gun elderly grocery
store owner as he made his way home with
the day's takings if 20 years behind
bars sounds like a lot for a mugging
that's because it was and this harsh
sentence was about to backfire
spectacularly on the U.S justice system
still young and impressionable Dillinger
fell in with a group of seasoned bank
robbers who were only too Keen to pass
on the tips of their trade to an eager
new Apprentice
then reform him prison acted as a crime
cocoon for the young Dillinger when he
emerged 10 years later the criminal
caterpillar had metamorphosized into a
badass Bank rubbing butterfly with a
hunger for the sweet green nectar that
was hidden in Bank vaults all over the
American Midwest
might have gotten a bit carried away
with that metaphor there sorry Dillinger
was paroled in May 1933 with the Great
Depression blighting America and no jobs
to be found lucky for him the sort of
work he was interested in didn't require
an interview and if anyone asked for
references he would simply refer them to
his new business associate a Mr Tommy
Gun
he rubbed his first bank just a month
after he was released from prison making
off with ten thousand dollars he hit
four more banks in the next three months
each time stealing thousands of dollars
in cash
but just when Dylan just fledgling
criminal career was taking off the
police course up with him once more
tracking him down to his apartment after
a robbery in Ohio there they discovered
two thousand dollars in hard cash as
well as guns ammunition and detailed
notes on the best escape routes from
various cities he couldn't have looked
guiltier if he'd been wearing an iHeart
bankrupting t-shirt they also found what
looked like detailed plans for a
jailbreak of some kind but Dillinger
refused to tell the police what they
were for
a few days later it became obvious
Dillinger had put together an escape
plan for some of the convict comrades
he'd left behind in prison a few months
earlier
four days after his arrest that plan was
put into action and eight of his buddies
soon to be famous across the U.S as the
first members of the Dillinger gang
busted out of jail
the first item on their to-do list was
to liberate their leader so free of the
gang members Harry Pete Pierpont Charles
mackley and Russell Clark hightailed its
to Lima County Jail where Dillinger was
being held following his recent arrest
it was too well guarded to go in old
guns blazing so the men pretended to be
members of the Indiana State Police
there to take Dillinger back to his old
prison now for some inexplicable reason
the officer's holding Dillinger didn't
believe these Rough and Ready gangster
types could possibly be their colleagues
Pierpont solved this little problem by
shooting the sheriff in the head
with their Inglorious leader now back on
the streets the gang set back to work
once more blazing a trail across the
Midwest robbing banks in Ohio Indiana
and Wisconsin
the newly formed Dillinger gang plans
their heist with military Precision they
would case a new Target weeks in advance
to identify weaknesses and learn staff
shift patterns detailed maps of the
surrounding area were drawn up to guide
the dedicated getaway driver he would be
given the fastest car available in case
of trouble gang members are all given
clearly defined roles some would be
Lookouts others will be tasked with
getting into the Vault and still others
would provide crowd control no matter
their role all were provided with high
quality weapons and body armor
the local police didn't know what had
hit them the Dillinger gang were just
too professional too well prepared
obviously the police were used to
criminals being reliably [__] at their
jobs they grew so confident they even
began targeting the police themselves
breaking into weapon stashes in multiple
police stations to steal machine guns
rifles pistols and bulletproof vests
from the very people who'd been charged
with stopping the bed
the Dillinger gang was also utterly
ruthless gunning down anyone who
threatens their operations including
police officers two were shot dead in
just two months in late 1934.
following the cold-blooded murders
Dillinger thought it would be a good
idea if the gang went on a little Lads
holiday for a while and so in January
1934 most of the crew ended up in Tuscan
Arizona
until the 20th century was a time when
lots of people like to smoke and
everything was made of wood
you could say it was an accident waiting
to happen and it did happen all over the
hotel Dillinger and his men were staying
in during the ensuing chaos a fireman
recognized Dillinger and tipped off the
police who arrived shortly afterwards to
arrest the entire gang
by this point Dillinger had already
broken out of prison once and
masterminded the breakout of eight of
his gang members so the authorities saw
to it that he was housed in the most
secure prison available an institution
with so many guards on such high walls
that escape was utterly impossible
well not impossible just a little bit
tricky over the space of several weeks
Dillinger used a razor blade to carve a
semi-realistic looking gun out of wood
with the help of a new friend notorious
gangster Babyface Nelson he used this
completely harmless stick to convince
the guard to let him and 15 of his
friends simply walk out of the front
door yet again Dillinger wasted no time
getting back in the saddle robbing a
bank in South Dakota just three days
after his daring escape and knocking off
one in Iowa a week after that in those
two robberies alone the gang got away
with one hundred thousand dollars the
equivalent of over 1.8 million today or
six large cappuccinos from Starbucks by
this point the authorities were getting
desperate throwing everything they had
at the Dillinger problem they put
together a dedicated 40-man Dillinger
unit and even placed a sneaky call to
the FBI precursor but the Bureau of
Investigation asking for assistance I'm
pretty sure they would have sent out a
bat signal if they thought it would have
helped in the end Batman wasn't required
[Music]
following a tip-off from a member of the
public the police tracked Dillinger and
his new girlfriend Evelyn frechette down
to an apartment in Saint Paul Minnesota
after a brief police Stakeout Dillinger
went on the offensive bursting out of
the front door cradling a tummy gun in
his arms a massive gunfight ensued
during which Dillinger took a bullet to
defy ending his days is an adventurer
like you and forcing him to retreat
inside where he and Evelyn were able to
sneak out of the back door and into a
waiting car they made their escape but
the shootout proved to be a turning
point in the case
Dillinger's gang had been scattered and
the police were starting to pick them
off one by one arresting some and
shooting others Dillinger himself laid
late with family in Chicago to recover
from his wound but Evelyn was picked up
by the police whilst visiting a friend
much to their annoyance she flatly
refused to give up to Linda's
whereabouts a noble act that saw her
promptly put in prison
with the arrest of his girlfriend
Dylan's one-man war against the
authorities went into overdrive late one
night he and gang member Homer Von meter
took a police officer hostage they then
marched a terrified cup to the local
police station at gunpoint and demanded
bulletproof vests and guns
rumor has a Dillinger was gearing up to
break Evelyn out of custody but in the
end he never got that chance
as he was putting together his plan the
bureau got a tip off that some
suspicious characters were staying at
the little Bohemian Lodge outside of the
Tiny Town of manitowish waters in
Wisconsin yet another gunfighting sued
and in what was fast becoming a pretty
embarrassing tradition Dillinger somehow
miraculously escaped once again
by this stage he was not just one of the
most famous criminals in the country he
was one of the most famous people more
recognizable than most Hollywood movie
stars there was a ten thousand dollar
reward on his head and he was rarely out
of the papers for more than a day or two
when Ford found out he'd been using one
of their cars as a getaway vehicle they
created an entire ad campaign boasting
about sit
in other words it was getting pretty
bloody difficult for him to lie low
every single time he stepped outside he
was risking capture most people would
have solved as conundrum by simply
staying inside but John Dillinger was
not most people and so his solution was
a bit more drastic he hired dodgy
plastic surgeons to change his face
naturally he couldn't go to a regular
hospital he was more recognizable than
Santa by this point so the bloody work
took place in his mate's living room
this sofa bound botch job began
fantastically [__] bad when Dillinger
was given an overdose of an anesthetic
called IFA something that surgeons only
noticed after he turned completely blue
they responded quickly using a pair of
forceps to remove Dylan's tongue from
his throat whilst administering A
Primitive form of CPR much to their
relief his breathing resumes
after regaining their composure the
Craigslist doctors removed several scars
and moles from Dillinger's face
partially filled in the cleft in his
chin and an indentation in his nose and
tightened his cheeks using of all things
kangaroo tendons
48 hours later Dillinger looked in the
mirror for the first time and saw
staring back at him the same Goddamn
face
and out snipping off a couple of moles
and smoothing a few lines here and there
does absolutely nothing to change what
you actually look like so Dillinger then
asked his dark web docs to carry out a
second procedure he wanted his
fingerprint removed as it happens the
doctors had just developed a new method
of doing exactly that
now if you happen to be of a sensitive
disposition best to stick your fingers
in your ears for the next 10 seconds or
so don't worry that isn't the first step
of the procedure by the way they use the
scalpel to slice away the top few layers
of skin from each finger before applying
concentrated hydrofluoric acid to the
open wounds burning away what's ever
remained of the prince
of the plastic surgery the fingerprint
removal was largely unsuccessful the
prints were partially destroyed but not
enough to prevent identification but in
the end it didn't really matter because
the net was rapidly closing in on John
Dillinger and this time there would be
no dramatic Escape aided by bark based
deception with an arboreal Armament in
June 1934 he started dating part-time
prostitutes Polly Hamilton
Hamilton's boss was a famous brothel
owner called Anna Cooper Nash and
despite Dillinger's recent painful
makeover she recognized him at once on
the 22nd of July 1934 Anna alerted the
authorities that she Polly and Dillinger
would be going to watch a film that
night at the Biograph Theater in Chicago
determined not to let America's Most
Wanted Man slip through their fingers
for the 10th millionth time agents have
circled the cinema whilst the film
played out inside when Dillinger finally
emerged he found himself facing a firing
squad six shots were fired and four
found their mark
one entered the back of dylinder's neck
as he tried to run severing his spinal
cord and exiting through his cheek you
can see the exit wound in each of the
four death masks made in the following
days
even before his corpse had been taken
away ghoulish souvenir Hunters descended
on the spot where he'd been slain to dip
their clothing and handkerchiefs into
his still warm blood
prior to his burial Dillinger's body was
put on public display in the morgue and
000 people came to see it in just over a
day
a bank robber to his rotten core he was
also a celebrity to the very last
[Music]
thanks for watching